[Applause]
usually on the day after a game we will
spend the first half hour of the show at
the most talking about that game last
night's game justifies further
explanation and analysis because of
lamar jackson the mvp front runner the
guy who is unstoppable right now in the
national football league after the game
sean mcgate coach of the rams was
specifically asked what makes lamar
jackson so hard to stop
you can't truly simulate that especially
when you look at just what a great job
they do of creating the conflict i mean
when you look at when it is some of
those gives downhill those things hit
fast they're on the second and third
levels and then when lamar does pull it
on some of their zone read plays you
know he's got the ability to to get
around you and then he you know what he
can do as a runner just feeling space
you know because you're not tackling
during the week you know those those do
make it very very difficult you know to
simulate those types of things and and
they do a great job of creating conflict
for a defense
because you're not tackling during the
week that struck me when i saw it and
heard it the first time chris because
what has the nfl become and i'm not
making a value judgment here this is
just teams reacting to the way the game
has changed teams don't practice live
tackling like they used to teams don't
have that smash you in the mouth
intensity in training camp like they
used to you don't have the tackling to
the ground you don't have the intense
padded practices you don't have the
practice tackling opponents so when you
come across opponents who are hard to
tackle
what the hell do you do yeah what do you
do you get beaten up physically because
you've got lamar jackson running
downhill you've got mark ingram who is
better now than he ever was with the
saints he's a bully he plows into the
line and you can't stop him well that's
the bar jackson effect but yeah you
think
and i think that this is a direct
product of teams recognizing if you're
not going to practice tackling then
we're going to run the ball more because
you're not going to be able to tackle us
like you would have been able to 10 and
15 years ago because you're not good at
tackling anymore because nobody's good
at tackling anymore well yeah added to
the fact that college football has
spread football and high school football
has spread football and everybody throws
the ball 40 times a game that's why
we've seen teams like new england and
new orleans and even the rams before
this you know and you look at all in the
you know the minnesota vikings right now
you look at a lot of the teams other
than the kansas city chiefs the last few
years and the final four the final eight
their run first football teams because
like middle linebackers come out of
college and they're like what two
pulling guards are running at me what a
fullback's about to hit me holy cow i
never had to do this all i had to worry
about was the bubble screen or a slant
behind me now i gotta take on a blocker
and try to make a tackle so that is
right also coaches have to be really
they have to they have to game plan
through the year
or not game plan but plan it out
correctly about when you do have your
full padded practice and when you are
gonna actually hit and do those things
yeah they're limited in the nfl now so
you have to be very strategic and when
you do that uh and you know this is it's
an issue in the nfl we hear you and i
hear coaches complain about it all the
time so you gotta find some way to get
it done still um hey the really good
teams in football still are winning the
physical battle and the ravens the 49ers
the new orleans saints the new england
patriots again i go back to my bar fight
thing they are ready if it br a fart a
fight breaks out they are gonna if a
fart breaks out bart breaks out they i
don't know how they'll do in that but if
a fight breaks out they're gonna kick
some butt and the seahawks are in that
too with all the big bad mofos they got
up front on both sides of the ball and
that's the still the name of the game is
who can dominate the line of scrimmage
and the ravens can dominate it as good
as anybody in football
i got two points i want to get to before
we take our next break first first
we eventually figured out what defenses
would do to patrick mahomes after having
the benefit of an offseason to devise a
scheme right right
drop back take away the spectacular
plays force them to be patient etc
what do they get what is the blueprint
that bill belichick is going to bring to
the afc championship game right for how
to defend lamar jackson and will we see
next year an inevitable softening
remember last year the narrative was
well uh it's going to work the first
time you play the ravens for them second
time through you'll know how to handle
it look at what the chargers did after
losing them in late december and then
beating them in the postseason i mean
what is going to be that kryptonite for
this lamar jackson led offense yeah well
you're going to have to take some
chances for one just like when you were
playing a great peyton manning or a tom
brady at times you just gotta do some
things that maybe you don't feel
comfortable about that are totally sound
but you just gotta take a chance to get
them behind the chain chains things like
that the other thing is hey this offense
is more complex than the kansas city
chiefs it's going to be harder you know
lamar's become a better thrower and
they've added more wrinkles to the run
game added to the fact which i want to
make this point hollywood brown is the
second most important person on the
baltimore ravens team because he is the
other guy where you go man we want to
crowd the line of scrimmage but are we
gonna lead this little fast you know
fast dude on the outside one on one all
game and then hey the draft this year on
the baltimore ravens get another
hollywood brown because lamar can throw
it the conference is there you get
hollywood brown with another fast guy
out there what are you gonna do when
they put two fast guys on their field
with two tight ends and that run game in
lamar they're gonna put you in a bind
but it's complex it really is and they
keep you off balance what mcveigh says
and uh i don't know i mean again they're
a tough match up for the patriots
because of what i said in the last pod
the patriots don't have a lot of big
guys they have a lot of db's and
linebackers and bill is going to have to
come up with something really really
creative to stop them
remember in the off season when the
ravens couldn't find any receivers to
join the team as free agents i don't
think they'll have that
me me i'll come please all right here's
my other question for you
as these remaining teams get ready to
play the ravens in the regular season
and more importantly in the postseason
yeah who in the hell is going to play
scout team quarterback
as you begin to try to assimilate what
lamar jackson does how do you prepare to
face lamar jackson when there's no one
out there on any of these rosters
remotely close to what lamar jackson can
do no nobody's going to be able to
totally do that you're exactly right i
mean that was a problem for for us the
tampa bay buccaneers when we used to
have to play michael vick it was a big
issue you know you you're like i would
think the 49ers this week they might
have to put marquise goodwin in there ed
scout team and he's gonna have to play
you know quarterback with all the run
plays and do that and then when it comes
time to throw they're gonna have to find
somebody to throw the ball instead of
letting him throw the ball you know i
think that's what you have to do you're
gonna have to find somebody at least
that can somewhat replicate the speed
but you're not gonna replicate exactly
what lamar jackson does you're exactly
right it's very tough on teams and uh
the teams that really you know this is
why i'm excited for this 49ers matchup
this week the 49ers have a lot of big
bad dudes on the front four so they're
our team where i go oh this could be
interesting you know if we talk about
front fours being able to get to great
quarterbacks and manning and brady and
rogers and being able to drop seven well
it's gonna almost stand stand the truth
here with with the ravens you need a
front four that you can just feel can
handle the the physicality up front and
then maybe you can do some things on the
edge to slow down lamar jackson and
that's really what's gonna be fun to
watch about that that matchup this week
and as it relates to the scout team
issue see i was trying to lead you down
a certain path right because the topic
came up a couple of weeks ago when there
was a day where it seemed like a certain
exiled quarterback may get a chance and
one of the reasons to bring him back
isn't necessarily to put him on the
field to be your starter but there is a
free agent quarterback out there and i
don't need to name names who would be
the closest thing you could get right
now to the lamar jackson scout team
quarterback now i don't know that he'd
be interested and that's part of the
problem and i made a point over the
weekend you know we don't know what
he'll do because he hasn't said what
he'll do he hasn't said i'll take
anything you give me but there's there's
merit to the idea of having colin
kaepernick as your scout team
quarterback and you can shout me down
people all you want because you think
i'm trying to get the guy a job but if
you want to win football games if you
want to beat the ravens in the playoffs
you have colin kaepernick as your scout
team quarterback you're going to be
better prepared to face lamar jackson
than you would be with marquis goodwin
or whatever backup quarterback that
isn't even close to remotely having the
physical skills that lamar jackson has
chris no well i listen i i get what
you're saying a hundred percent and he
is a guy that could somewhat replicate
what lamar jackson's doing as far as
being able to throw the ball and scary
on the edge when he does keep the ball
and running and all those things yes uh
the other thing is it's just hard to
replicate the ravens in general you know
again you know if you're sitting at home
pull up your laptop open it up check out
that ravens roster it's it's the o-line
it's one
320-pounder after another and 330 and
335 and that's where they dominated the
rams too hey
aaron donald's 280 pounds i don't care
how great you are when you got a when
you're getting pushed by you know two
330 pounders and a double team you know
damn superman is gonna have a hard time
with that and aaron donald's the closest
thing we've seen to superman so you
gotta have big people on your defensive
line to slow this tac attack down and
the quarterback thing yeah i mean the
kaepernick thing's not going to happen
mike but uh it's a very i'm just saying
if you want if you want to be if you
want to be ready to beat the ravens
that's a got to consider meanwhile aaron
donald best defensive player in the nfl
invisible invisible thanks to what the
ravens did
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports